I spent a lot of time researching
material for my monologues this week and
when we do that we sometimes come across
news stories that are so completely
bizarre you can't believe they're true
so here to present some of these stories
is Atlanta's expert on all things
Ludacris rap artist Christopher Ludacris
bridges
thank you thank you Conan appreciate
that in the town of York Pennsylvania
a dog sitting in a parked car
accidentally shifted the vehicle into
drive and hit a pedestrian no one got
hurt but getting run over by a dog
now that's ludicrous
[Music]
a company based out of Seattle has just
come out with a condom that smells and
tastes like bacon a bacon flavored
condom
now that's looted in Louisiana a 44 year
old man beat his 77 year old father with
a birthday cake now that's the classic
example of family dysfunction I really
hope they'd get some counseling
but beating somebody's ass with a
birthday cake now that salute
[Music]
and finally right here in Atlanta a
rapper has recorded six platinum-selling
albums earned three Grammys three BT
Awards a Screen Actors Guild Award and
is appearing in Fast & Furious 6 coming
out Memorial Day weekend and he still
has time to devote to his own Charitable
Foundation
Wow that's incredible no Conan that's
ludicrous
[Applause]